[Musique]
[Rires]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de mode d'emploi avec un focus
sur les métiers du numérique un volet
consacré à la formation
sans oublier bien sûr notre rubrique ces
entreprises recrutent à saint quentin en
yvelines
tout de suite le sommaire illustration
des métiers liés au numérique au sein de
la société ever data base à montigny le
bretonneux et l'équipe est spécialisée
dans les solutions de stockage en ligne
pour les entreprises pour devenir un
expert du web des formations existent
comment se former par exemple au métier
de community manager nous avons poussé
les portes de l'organisme
il faut coop en plateau erwan le gall et
le délégué à l'emploi et à l'insertion
professionnelle à 50 en libye nous en
dira plus également sur des formations
nouvellement labellisé école du
numérique
enfin si vous êtes à la recherche d'un
emploi ne manquez pas notre rendez vous
consacré aux entreprises qui recrutent
trois offres proposées par l' agence
pôle emploi de trappes avec les objets
connectés qui rythment notre quotidien
depuis maintenant ces dernières années
le secteur du numérique est en pleine
expansion
on dénombre d'ailleurs pas moins de 80
métiers un domaine est dynamique
notamment à saint quentin en yvelines
qui concentre sur son territoire de
nombreux établissements liés au
numérique
exemple avec la société ever data
[Musique]
implantés défient 2014 à montigny le
bretonneux la société et leur date avec
une forte offre proposant des solutions
de stockage en ligne pour les tpe et aux
pme
une dizaine de salariés a valu les
package ou aujourd'hui c'est de proposer
en fait deux entreprises tout un service
élaboré donc de maintenance
d'intervention de support ainsi que les
logiciels qui vont avec par rapport à
leurs besoins et leurs projets pourquoi
ce choix justement de s'implanter ici
sur territoire de 50 en ville
ben il s'avère que saint quentin en
yvelines et
très actif aujourd'hui c'est la deuxième
région parisienne qui est le plus
développé au niveau des start up
donc on a choisi d'être ici aussi pour
accompagner justement toutes ces
start-up pour pour l'innovation est
également aussi pour toutes les écoles
qui sont très réputés aux alentours qui
sont liées justement au numérique
[Musique]
tout part de cette box là est donc cette
box là en fait combine le cloud et le
réseau local
donc il s'agit d'un petit serveur acheté
une petite boîte 30 sur 30 cm que les
clients peuvent installer donc chez eux
dans la société et ainsi pourront avoir
accès donc surtout leur poste tablette
téléphone compris donc les logiciels
microsoft donc tout ce qui va être liées
à office 365
vous avez rejoint cette société il ya un
mois pourquoi je suis actuellement un
master en stratégie commerciale pour
réaliser de la banque d'affaires voilà
sur le long terme mais j'imagine pour
faire ce métier
faut quand même avoir des connaissances
dans le monde du numérique oui tout à
fait il faut avoir des connaissances que
l'on acquiert donc à l'école mais
également sur le terrain c'est pour cela
que j'ai choisi l'alternance et cela
fait cinq ans que je travaille dans le
secteur numérique haïti donc je connais
un petit peu le marché désormais
[Musique]
aujourd'hui 200 tpe et pme font appel
aux services de la société ever data des
métiers du numérique avec bien souvent
des salaires attractifs mais qui peine à
trouver et bien des candidats faute de
qualification à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'organisme il
faut coop propose tout au long de
l'année des formations pour adultes dans
le domaine du web digital notamment les
profils des stagiaires sont très
différents comme vous allez le voir dans
ce reportage
[Musique]
créée il ya près de 50 ans le groupe il
faut coop est un organisme de formation
pour adultes spécialisée dans le domaine
tertiaire
le centre de montigny le bretonneux
existe depuis 2015 et propose des
formations dans l'immobilier
le secrétariat les ressources humaines
et le wat digital
[Musique]
annick léon bonjour argent je vous êtes
responsable de la formation community
manager ici à il faut coop alors c'est
une formation qui fait partie du pôle
web digital est ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire plus
à saint quentin en yvelines nous
accompagnons des professionnels des
adultes en formation professionnelle sur
les métiers du community management et
du développement donc community manager
développeur intégrateur web développeur
intégrateur web orienté objet à raison
de trois sessions par an de façon à
offrir soit aux salariés soit aux
personnes désireuses de faire une
formation complète
trois dates différentes et trois
sessions différentes là que ce principal
d'activité d'un community manager c'est
de proposer une stratégie digitale à
toute entreprise quelle que soit sa
taille sa structure son activité à la
suite de cette formation on a un diplôme
on a un diplôme c'est l'équivalent d'un
diplôme alors que l'ifop est un
organisme certificateur reconnu
donc nous avons nos propres diplômes en
titre
[Musique]
ghislaine bonjour je vais vous suivez la
formation de community manager depuis un
petit peu plus d'un mois ici à l'ifop
alors pourquoi avez vous décidé de
suivre cette formation et bien tout
simplement parce que dans mon précédent
emploi gto faysal facility manager d'un
grand groupe d'un centre d'excellence de
formation et au sein de ce groupe une
restructuration et donc j'ai été amenée
être sur le marché du travail et lors de
mes recherches j'ai constaté plusieurs
annonces ou ont recherché des
responsables des services centraux qui
est l'équivalent de bons titres en
anglais avec des compétences de
community manager ça consiste en quoi
cette cette formation donc depuis un peu
plus d'un mois vous faites quoi
concrètes alors cette formation déjà ce
qui est important c'est qu'on a 4 mois
de théorie et 4 - 2 stages pratiques
alors cette formation est basé surtout
sur toutes les dernières technologies
aussi bien l'utilisation de photoshop
pour faire créer des sites sur presse
j'ai fait une licence en marketing qui
auquel j'ai pas été formés aux métiers
du numérique où tout ce qui est l'aspect
technique
donc c'est pour ça que ça complétaient
parfaitement mon cursus alors
concrètement qu'est ce que vous attendez
à l'issue de cette formation à l'issue
de cette formation obtenir un emploi
parce que c'est le but quand même de
l'ifocop c'est de nous prédisposé aux
métiers du numérique mais elle a créé
obtenir un emploi qui vont nous
permettre d'entrer des îles
définitivement pardon dans le digital
donc c'est vraiment là l'objectif final
conventionnée par le ministère de
l'économie l'organisme il faut coop de
montigny le bretonneux forme chaque
année près de 150 personnes en 2016 100
% des stagiaires ayant suivi la
formation community managers ont trouvé
retrouver un emploi et bientôt sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
il y aura encore plus de structures pour
se former aux métiers du numérique grâce
au label école du numérique vient de
mettre en place l'agglomération pour en
parler en détail
erwan le gall est avec nous bonjour
bonsoir alors vous êtes élue déléguée à
l'emploi et à l'insertion
professionnelle à 50 en yvelines
du 15 juin au 15 juillet dernier
l'agglomération a lancé donc un appel à
labellisation destiné aux structures de
formation alors ça y est on connaît les
lauréats on en parlera dans quelques
instants les avants pourquoi
l'agglomération a décidé de mettre en
place ce dispositif
c'est très simple 5000 besoin sur le
territoire dans le numérique
1300 là dès demain il a fallu mettre en
place et actionnez rapidement des
formations dédiées à ces besoins
nationale leur seul territoire
c'est vraiment pressent donc on a
lancé cet appel à projets ou différentes
organismes ont répondu donc satanisation
pas servir à être reconnu sur le
territoire et surtout rassurer les chefs
d'entreprise les entreprises du
territoire qui en ont réellement besoin
est ce que ça veut dire donc que les
gens ne sont pas finalement assez
qualifiés pour pour ce métier ça veut
dire que les gens sont qualifiés mais
d'avoir une labellisation ça permet
d'être identifié plus précisément sur le
territoire et je parle bien du
territoire j'aimerais d'ailleurs le
territoire est important alors combien
de des structures de formation était
retenue après cet appel alors une
demi-douzaine avec un différents
critères
il faut savoir comme je tiens à dire que
dans cette sélection
il y avait quand même beaucoup beaucoup
de chefs d'entreprises donc je vis voilà
alors ce sont des structures qui ne sont
pas encore présentes pour certaines sur
le territoire de 50 en disent long elle
doit donc présenter effectivement des
formations ces formations viendront sur
le territoire
par rapport aux besoins il ya entendu là
sur divers reportages community manager
la cybersécurité c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut renforcer sur le territoire
et puis d'autres stratégies numériques
voilà donc un certain nombre et un panel
je n'ai pas tous en tête mais alors
concrètement ce label va apporter quoi
finalement
comme je l'aï dit il va apporter une
plus value pour les chefs d'entreprise
qui ont besoin et des grands comptes qui
ont besoin de techniciens rapidement
donc il ya ce cursus bonnes questions à
se poser
un rapport aux candidats lorsqu'ils vont
se présenter d'être passé d'être passé
par cette formation labellisée permettra
d'avoir une garantie supplémentaire ça
existe déjà ces formations sur
territoire sur certains organismes
mais là nous renforçons nous on l'a la
coopération voila voila et des
formations qui seront donc opérationnel
début 2010 81 100 personnes
une centaine de stagiaires début 18 de
luge auriez 2018 merci et juan magan
bien pour votre intervention
alors maintenant si vous êtes à la
recherche d'un emploi et bien un conseil
prenez de quoi noter voici et trois
offres proposées par l' agence pôle
emploi de trappes
bonjour que si clotilde jestin
conseillère entreprises au pôle emploi
de trappes
je vais vous présenter aujourd'hui trois
offres d'emploi qui sont à pourvoir dès
que possible
tout d'abord le comité régional sport
pour tous de trappes recherche un ou une
secrétaire comptable en cdi 28 heures
hebdomadaires
au niveau des compétences qui sont
demandés c'est la saisie
l'enregistrement de pièces comptables
le rapprochement vous effectuez
également l'accueil physique et
téléphonique ainsi que diverses tâches
administratives type gestion du courrier
autonomie rigueur rigueur et sens de
l'organisation sont des qualités
professionnelles qui sont recherchés
pour ce poste deuxième offre présentée
aujourd'hui c'est l'entreprise de cas
poste dps2 trappe qui est une filiale
privée du groupe la poste et qui recrute
un ou une opérateurs de production
cette entreprise travaille avec de
grands groupes est allé chargée de
l'impression en nombre de divers
documents types de teintes salaires
relevé de courant au niveau des
compétences se demander la principale et
la maîtrise de l'outil informatique et
les qualités professionnelles qui sont
recherchés sont le travail en équipe
ainsi que la capacité d'adaptation et
enfin dernière offre l'enseigne la
maison d'ursule située à maurepas
donc c'est un magasin qui vend du tissu
mercerie linge de maison ainsi que
décoration de la maison recherche un ou
une vendeurs à temps plein il s'agit
d'un poste polyvalent où vous accueillez
les clients vous effectuez le conseil
ainsi que la vente mais vous faites
également la mise en rayon et la découpe
de tissu vous avez le sens du contact
client vous êtes réactif souriant et
avenant postuler dès à présent avant de
se quitter un rendez vous à ne pas
manquer jeudi 16 novembre la ville de
coignières organise la 15e journée de
recrutement
cela se déroule de 9h30 à 16h au salon
antoine de saint-exupéry pour plus
d'informations un numéro le 01 30 13 17
66 voilà c'est la fin de ce numéro merci
de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve mardi 21
novembre pour un nouveau mode d'emploi
consacré cette fois ci aux métiers de
l'industrie à très bientôt
[Musique]
[Rires]